[Music]  spies  saboteurs  assassins  we've all done terrible things on behalf  of the rebellion  cassian ander  don't matter what you tell me or tell  yourself  you'll ultimately die fighting these  bastards  wouldn't you rather give it all at once  to something real  [Music]  we've chosen a side  we're fighting against the dark  there is an organized rebel effort drill  down and get a hunt started  you realize what you said in motion  people will suffer  time has come to force their hand  at what cost  everything  every day we wait  they get stronger  let's take them by surprise  for the greater good call it what you  have  let's call it war  people are standing up  they're afraid right now they're afraid  star wars and or three episode premiere  streaming september 21st  [Music]  you